para unos pocos fue un día más en la
capital chilena para otros primer día de
libertad tras varios meses de
restricciones
estábamos colapsando el elevado número
de contagios de coronavirus que registró
la capital chilena obligó a las
autoridades a implementar una de las más
largas y restrictivas cuarentenas la
movilidad fue limitada en mínimos
lugares emblemáticos de la ciudad fueron
cerrados sabemos que es una etapa
positiva porque vamos avanzando en este
paso a paso pero también decirles que
estamos en pandemia estamos en pandemia
y si no respetamos las medidas y se
aumentan los casos vamos a tener que
retroceder cosas que las personas no
quieren hacer porque el impacto negativo
que tiene estar en cuarentena es muy
grande no solamente para ellos sino que
para toda la familia para muchos de
quienes estuvieron bajo las
restricciones la retoma de actividades
era ya un imperativo la gente necesita
trabajar
pero creo que no están dadas las
condiciones todavía porque si tú me
preguntas si en el puente hasta tuvimos
cuarentena nunca la hubo el zoológico de
la ciudad y sitios para tomar un café
estuvieron entre los más visitados
después de siete meses buen show vuelve
a abrir sus puertas en el cne una etapa
que hoy te estamos con un recorrido que
es diferente con reservas con una serie
de cosas que no son parte de nuestra
cultura para visitar lugares como el
nuestro chile es la sexta nación en
américa latina' más afectada por casos
de coronavirus con casi 460 mil
contagios y más tec 12 mil muertes y en
menos de un mes el país celebrará un
plebiscito nacional por una nueva
constitución